hey youtubers its charlie huge news
Robbie Amell just confirmed along with
Andrew Kreisberg that they're going to
be bringing Deathstorm on to the flash
season 2 now this requires a bunch of
explanation because they're not doing
blackest night they're not doing Green
Lantern's stuff they're just bringing
Robbie Amell back onto the show as Earth
to Ronnie just in case you haven't seen
the beginning of the flash season 2
spoilers from the flash season 2 episode
1 so here we go
so what happened at the end of season 1
when Barry went back in time he created
this giant wormhole that was going to
eat the entire planet and in the
beginning of season 2 in season 2
episode 1 earth 1 Ronnie and Martin
Stein had to decouple the firestorm
matrix at its center that worked but it
seemed like Ronnie ended up dying
because only Martin Stein came back so a
lot of people were wondering what
happened to Earth when Ronnie it really
is just Robbie Amell leaving the show
for a period of time but he's a great
friend of everyone obviously he's Steven
Amell his cousin they're always gonna
try and bring him back whenever they can
and because it's the comic book universe
there are so many ways to explain how
characters come back from the dead or
how they can come back as different
versions of characters so what the TV
show is doing is giving us earth to
Ronnie who is a villain in calling
himself death storm they're not doing
the original death storm from the comics
now there is a new 52 version of
firestorm from Earth 3 that calls
himself death storm but that's actually
just Martin Stein so I'm actually gonna
explain who Deathstorm is really quick I
have to explain a little bit of blackest
night but basically the TV show is just
using the name for an evil version of
firestorm from earth to that is Ronnie
Raymond who will be married to killer
frost that was the other little bit he's
gonna be married to Caitlin snow of
Earth - who is killer frost so it'll be
like a Bonnie and Clyde kind of thing
where it's like oh it's so much more fun
to be bad but death storm in the comics
is basically a Black Lantern version of
Ronnie Raymond who was resurrected by
nekron and then became fused with the
firestorm matrix like the resurrected
Ronnie fused with the firestorm matrix
to become death storm now if you haven't
read blackest night it's this big
sweeping Green Lantern story that
crossed across the entire DC universe it
involved every single character that DC
had anybody that was dead
was resurrected and came back as a
lantern but part of the Black Lantern
Corp so they're all really evil
eventually the heroes are able to
destroy the black lantern battery
getting rid of all the black lantern
rings basically D powering all the
villains but the strongest of the black
lanterns are able to continue on without
their Black Lantern rings death storm is
one of those characters when resurrected
Ronnie Raymond fuses with the firestorm
matrix he kind of becomes his own
Lantern battery like his own power
generation source so while death storm
is running around he basically just
tries to torture jason rusch to just do
the most evil things possible like he
turns his girlfriend to salt death storm
has the same powers as firestorm and one
that we haven't seen on the TV show yet
that I think they'll do on legends of
tomorrow is transmutation he can change
the molecular structure of physical
objects so Jason Rusch has this love
interest and death storm is like boom
turn you into salt very evil very
twisted now of course Jason Rusch isn't
someone they're doing on the TV show
they're doing the Jax Jackson character
and I think the reason why they're not
doing like a resurrected earth one
Ronnie death storm is because they don't
want to make it too complicated but now
that we do have earth - Ronnie firestorm
at some point in the future they can pit
him against Jax Jackson and it'll be
like a who is the real firestorm like
you're the imposter firestorm I'm the
real firestorm I think we can all agree
that it'd be awesome for them to try a
blackest night storyline at some point
but they have to do Green Lantern first
there was a Green Lantern Easter Egg on
arrow season four there was an H Jordan
nametag in a bar in Coast City but I
that's as close as we've gotten to Green
Lantern so far so at some point they're
either gonna have to
shit-or-get-off-the-pot
but I think it's gonna be a long time
before they'll be able to do an actual
Green Lantern storyline so just to recap
what the TV show is doing is earth to
Ronnie Raymond who is calling himself
death storm who is basically just an
evil version of firestorm who is married
to killer frost and they'll be like
Bonnie and Clyde
probably tasked by zoom with beating the
out of the flash just to make the
flash stronger we know now after the
mid-season finale the zoom just wants to
make the flash more full of Speed Force
so that he can fatten him up like
Christmas goose and steal more Speed
Force now some of you may have heard me
talk about crime syndicate earth like
earth three four
the comics that's kind of what they're
doing with earth-2 on the TV show the
flashes earth-2 is all about a bunch of
metahumans being created but them all
kind of turning evil it sounds like zoom
the evil version of the flash on that
world is slowly turning metahumans evil
or killing them off like he's probably
giving them as a choice you can work
with me do what I say or I'll kill you
so it's like okay I guess I guess we'll
be bad earth two in the comics is more
like the Golden Age characters like the
Justice Society world so the TV show is
really blending a lot of earth to comic
book things with earth three comic book
things with crime syndicate things if
you are big comic book fans and you
haven't been reading Darkseid ward
that's the the Justice League title that
Geoff Johns is writing right now he just
introduced some crime syndicate things I
don't wanna get too spoilery because
it's a really awesome comic book story
but check out Justice League Darkseid
war now the next big question is when
are we gonna see this because if they're
just shooting it right now they're
usually about six weeks out so I'm
guessing this this is either episode 15
or episode 16 there are a couple two
parters that we haven't seen yet
episode 10 is gonna air on the 19th then
arrow comes back on the 20th then
legends of tomorrow episode 1 airs on
the 21st now if you didn't see it I'll
put a link in the description but
there's a Suicide Squad Batman V
Superman Wonder Woman special that's
also coming on the 19th Captain America
Civil War also has a special that's
coming on the 19th there is a ton of
stuff happening on that Tuesday night so
I'll have like 5 videos that I'll have
to make in those 2 days but you guys are
gonna poop your pants there's so much
awesome stuff dropping just in case you
guys haven't seen it you can click here
for the flash season to kill or frost
trailer you know you finally get to see
caitlin snow as killer frost and you can
click here to learn all about that
Suicide Squad special that's coming
thank you so much for watching everybody
let's high five I'll see you guys
tonight